[Music]
I've been finding like that's been
escalating and escalating and escalating
is being annoying Courtney is with like
just doing anything court doesn't get
that her lack of decision-making does
affect other people
Khloe Kardashian is teaching her sister
a lesson about indecisiveness on
Sunday's Keeping Up with the Kardashians
really cute and let's just say Courtney
doesn't love getting a taste of her own
medicine I know she's meeting us here
so I'm gonna pretend that you and I are
like driving a whoa not here yet I'm
just gonna be like wait hold on we
changed our mind we're going somewhere
else
subject court I take with me literally
on a daily basis we're not going there
anymore go to Casa Vega I know it's far
but you take your ass over there
it's wrong we now my bad Suzanne do you
pull over for a second we change to go
to a different restaurant but mom's like
on the phone so I don't know exactly
where we're going
hello I'm so hungry I don't have time
not any restaurant
what's better than pulling a prank on
court and making her just feel what it
feels like when someone is that
indecisive I just want to live my life
and be happy